le temps des vacances c'est aussi le
temps de la nuit
après les sables d'olonne hier nous
sommes allés voir comment les nantais
passer leurs nuits alors avec le beau
temps lancé quelque peu vidé de ces
noctambules les branches et devrait
faire maintenant aller passer leurs
soirées sur la côte mais les amateurs de
nuit chaude on les trouve encore dans
des endroits bien spécifiques
marianne figure au et jean paul launay
les ont rencontrés hier soir il est 23h
la faune nocturne nantaise sort de sa
tanière il y en a de toutes les espèces
certaines très commune d'autres plus
rares
pourtant ils ont tous un foie en commun
la terrasse d'un café le ripou open que
sniffeur sans oublier l'éternel
nostalgiques du larzac
ils sont tous là entretiens secrets et
petit négoce discret la nuit place du
commerce c'est fou non
et heureusement la pression
ça vient ça dépend il ya des concerts
c'est bien mais
plus de concerts c'est bien en général
je crois un coup reçu sur la semaine au
terral je vais au cinoche je rends
compte du monde je vais en boîte ça
dépend pour ça
petite fête chez des cobayes robin
ça c'est des gens que je rencontrais sa
reconnaissance
et puis je les invitais dernière chez
moi c'est du sans changement de quartier
changement d'adressé ici on tape le
carton ambiance jazzy sourire complice
les clients sont des habitués tutoiement
de rigueur moyenne d'âge la trentaine on
sert bien on s'en souvient on y revient
ce que j'aime la musique et sous un fond
de musique là parce que autrement il ya
d'autres formes de musique qui me
dépasse un petit peu dit c'est le seul
qui peut leur être
peut-être bien que j'aime beaucoup le
jazz c'est un bien on ressent plus
sympathique et si ce soir
quand vous sortez autrement à nantes
vous fait quoi quand je sors je vais au
cinéma je fais comme tout le monde on
peut flâner dans les rues piétonnes
mais on se rend compte c'est ce trait
vie d'un petit peu de des anneaux de
glace du centre besoin qui peut te
retrouver un petit peu géré les sources
un petit pot de la musique un peu
différente minuit l'heure dé jeu de
massacre beaucoup sont déjà partis il
avait trop les boules
et
quand on plus âgés ce sont les plus
rouges tard quand les enfants sont
sortis c'est bien connu les parents ont
confuse wade laser et de discothèques
bcbg
ils viennent ici pour retrouver le
charme des bals d'antan valse tango au
son de l'accordéon
on oublie le décor et on est transporté
dans une guinguette d'autrefois
ne vous méprenez pas cependant ce n'est
pas ici que tout risque là a filmé son
bail l'ambiance est bon enfant ce s'il
se sent presque en famille on y vient
pour s'amuser mais pas toujours sans
arrière-pensée après tout c'est dans un
bail ne devront pas farc inconnu grand
maman qui a dit que les adeptes du rétro
ne sont plus dans le coup
une danse même disco faire la fête
l'apanage de la jeunesse
encore un but de plus aux oubliettes